the Gothard base tunnel is the longest
and deepest rail tunnel in the world 57
kilometers through the Alps literally
through it's called a base tunnel
because it's at the base of the Mountain
at its deepest point there are more than
two kilometers of rock above it's so far
down to the ground that the Earth in
there is hot without ventilation the air
temperature will be more than 40 degrees
around the turn of the century there
were two devastating fires in Road
tunnels under those mountains and the
authorities here in Switzerland want to
make sure that nothing like that can
ever happen again how they do that is
fascinating so here's what's going to
happen we're going to see the control
center the watches over the tunnel and
also visit one of the intervention
centers with the firefighters and First
Responders that'll step in if the worst
were to happen and then I want to show
you what I reckon is the most important
bit of safety equipment it isn't
anywhere near the tunnel and most people
will probably never notice it but before
that we start at the control center just
over there in the Qatar based tunnel
there are six freight trains and two
passenger trains per hour per Direction
this means that at the same time there
are several trains inside the tunnel in
both of the two tubes the cutter-based
tunnels divided into three-thirds if
there is a disturbance in one of these
thirds the train can be diverted at one
of the two changement points into the
other tube to bypass the Disturbed
section there are different sections to
control the traffic the signal box
controls the track the movement
Authority is is given by the signal box
and better traffic control if there is a
disturbance on one of the systems in the
tunnel then we have different
possibilities first of all we get
noticed by an alarm that there is a
problem they first of all try to fix the
problem remotely if this is not
successful they can send people on site
to try to fix it this channel is
actually a bit of a tourist attraction
in itself you can get driven in down the
service tunnel on a guided tour and end
up at this reinforced windproof visitors
window with eight centimeter thick glass
and watch the trains go by and anything
up to 230 kilometers an hour
that was terrifying
if a train has a technical problem first
of all the train driver tries to reboot
the train system if it's not successful
we have the firefighting train which
goes into the tunnel to tow out the
broken train in case of an incident in
the tunnel let's say a fire we have two
intervention centers North and South
intervention Center means firefighting
stations they get an alarm and within
five minutes usually both of the
firefighting trains go into the tunnel
from North and from South at the same
time to fight the fire they have the
obligation to be on any point in the
tunnel within 45 minutes Tire fighting
train is a convoy of firefighting trucks
on rail they bring water in foam liquid
they bring special equipment tools to
handle any possible situation inside the
tunnel the two emergency stops there is
a possibility to refill the water if
people have to be evacuated in the
tunnel they do not walk out of the town
because it's much too far the train
brings them to one of two evacuation
stations where the passengers can go
into the evacuation tube this evocation
tube is under pressure so fresh air is
streaming in they are safe because they
have enough oxygen and smoke cannot
enter then they go to the next
evacuation section where the evacuation
train is waiting for them we have to be
able to evacuate the entire town within
90 minutes as I went around today one of
the teams said that if there ever is an
evacuation or a fire in the tunnel
several other things had to go wrong
first yes you can never protect against
every possible weird circumstance but
you can try which brings me here to
what's basically the middle of nowhere
in Switzerland about 15 kilometers away
from the south entrance to the tunnel
and to this Gantry over the tracks 15
kilometers sounds like a lot but at the
speed Swiss trains can travel that could
be about four or five minutes and while
it doesn't look like much this Gantry
scans every train at speed before it
even gets near of the tunnel there were
sensors on the track around here too and
if the train has anything unbalanced any
hot spots that look out of place
anything poking out then it's not going
into the tunnel we have laser systems
which measure the profile of a train
maybe the load of a train has moved and
doesn't respect any more the necessary
profile to enter a tunnel we have heat
detection where we can detect overheated
axes or overheated brakes all these
controls they happen at usual commercial
speed of the trains on different points
all over Switzerland and we get about
200 alarms per day from these measuring
stations if we do not confirm an alarm
within 30 seconds the train is stopped
automatically it's not an emergency stop
it's but it's quite you you feel it if a
train seems to be wrong it gets to a
side track where it has to wait if the
inspection says this train is okay then
it can continue its Journey if not the
owner of to train has to resolve the
problem before the train can continue
its Journey yes there are lots of
systems in place for if the worst
happens but prevention is better than
cure and for me this Gantry is the most
important bit of safety equipment here
because the best solution is to stop
problems before they even start